I'm Charles I'm an auctioneer
I think the strangers we've had quite a
few we had a bottom which was part of
the salad Hussein statue that was
toppled in 2003 and the buck came in for
auction we've also had him for sell a
dinosaur egg on the day it never sold
because a vendor wants too much money
for it and then he went into hiding
because had a few threats and we haven't
heard from him since
one big cheek it was part of the bottom
and it was a left cheek it was quite
cumbersome yeah dinosaur egg six million
years old and we had it in this cabinet
on a very hot day it was almost like an
incubator I kept thinking could it hatch
you know it hatched a great price it
made almost a thousand pounds we did
sell a piece of toast that Prince
Charles left on his wedding breakfast
morning when he married Diana and that
piece of toast makes did longer than
exactly and when I first saw it as it
crumbs and it made 800 pounds three
pieces of ice would bye-bye with a
passion what you like by what is stylish
and what is forward-thinking first time
and by objects in good condition Chris I
challenge you in my antiques business to
rap about Chip and Dale yeah Mison which
is porcelain made from in Germany okay
and diamonds so Chippendale German
porcelain Meissen yeah and diamond this
is a freestyle about those young y'all
kick it up a flow about the Chippendale
talk about the furniture not the strip
in males year they get oiled up like a
wood wax I want to press their hard skin
with some thumbtacks but don't do that
really must take care to the fan cover
wooden spindles on the chair cuz you
don't want to
the value downward condition alike a
chair table sideboard condition so well
sell it on the rust from for lots of
money I like to wax it like bee wax not
honey and keep it preserved yo get the
value rising like some German tossolini
no I call it my sin not risin like the
poison in Japan Rising Sun year don't
want to denigrate land but my sin may be
made in the Black Forest I don't know
yeah I'm kind of at a loss when it comes
to antiques don't know about the
porcelaine but if I was rich money like
making it rain I maybe buy some put it
on my shelf and show up on my German
porcelain wealth people be like whoa you
got great taste and not be like walk
past with less haste otherwise you might
crack the plates and it'll fall and
that'll be hard I will be so what's
hauled last thing yo you want one more
how hard is the diamond on the moors
hardness scale not the mores like a
fellow i got diamonds on me cuz i'm a
flash hello i just don't
it's a garnet with the gold ring i want
to get some Zaman's and get an acting on
the drilling tip when i go to the earth
i just freestyle about diamonds nor a
hood
I love the diamonds like my name is Bugs
Bunny because they got carrots don't
look at me funny the diamonds buy some
Sun keeping the value down and there we
go yeah thank you we got an audience
behind the camera for the first time as
well and you stiffed me with my set